ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by Johnny and Youssef from
propane fitness comm remotely over the
interwebs in our isolation station hmm
from a distance
isolation stations isolation station
otherwise we'd have to be socially
distancing within the same isolation
station yeah I know
we are we'd just be walls apart wouldn't
even look at us look at us still doing a
podcast
Kovac can't stop this [ __ ] train you
can't you're right I can't
we have got no video Mandy neither no
wait he's actually in quarantine isn't
he
he's in a separate bit yeah waiting for
this file yeah well um we thought that
given the fact that the entire world has
just changed everyone's lifestyles are
dramatically altered in one form or
another people starting to work from
home the opportunity to go out and train
do social stuff they're opportunities
for business everything has been upended
dramatically we figured let's do
isolation hacks so this is it
isolation hacks 101 so Johnny hot potato
how are we starting catch it how are we
how we gonna frame isolation hacks so I
like to split mine between physical and
anyone gets that I'm quite well I
suppose any life hacks listeners will do
the way I see it is there's damage
control and then there's taking
advantage of it so there's how do I kind
of continue my everything that I would
have been doing normally as normal and
then how do I like spot the
opportunities and make the most of it so
I was speaking to our clients about this
the other day when all this is over more
than any other time probably in your
entire lives they'll be there'll be two
outcomes that you experience from people
you know there'll be some people who you
meet and you're like [ __ ] how are
your your way leaner like got like you
look way better like wow
look all the things you've achieved and
all the other people who like gained a
bit of weight
looking really pasty and pale and I
always I salute and so it's like decide
now more than any other time because
everyone's in the same Pitts position
you can be the person that gets to
impress all your friends off the back of
what you did in isolation how I said I
said this in a podcast at a week that
it's very rare that everybody on the
planet experiences the same thing you
know confused
that's just interesting face it it was
just when when Chris paused I thought
I'd been hot potatoes is this because
none of us actually look at each other's
faces
we're all just engrossed usually in what
Dean's doing behind the camera and
trying to think of our next life fact
but now I actually have to look you in
the eye yeah it's very rare right that
everybody on the planet has especially
everyone even even within a country but
everyone on the planet is experiencing
the same thing at the same time but it
doesn't even rain everywhere at the same
time you know like it can be sunny in
Newcastle and raining in London we don't
even experience the weather together but
everyone people in America people in
China they're all experiencing some
flavor of this same thing which is
social distancing social isolation
potentially working from home reduced
facilities worries about the economy
worries about work so yeah hopefully we
can provide people with some some tips
some tricks some hacks today I remember
one teen Asian this is a you gonna have
to bear with me here
I remember when tea nation release
indigo 3G does anyone else remember that
I remember when I bought it yeah so I
saved up and pour I was doing an
internship at the time and I bought it
they really spayed basically blueberries
and capsules and angle or it was like
it's a level playing field now
everybody's on in to go through GT I'm
thinking [ __ ] so cool like once
everyone's indigo 3G then it's that's
just my Rd work at that point like no
other time in training and diet is at a
level playing field and everyone
when absolutely everybody is on the
blueberry extracts and that's now are
you saying that this is that situation
I mean Yusuf's the one eating
blueberries out of a cut frantic this is
a proper life hack frozen berries pour
some hot water on and you can eat them
like a soup this is real this is the
real-life equivalent of everybody taking
them to go 3G everyone's on drugs except
me right okay let's go Johnny what have
you got first why don't we start tell
you what why don't we start with what I
think is the most important part which
is people's routines throughout the day
so I think that's the biggest change
that we're going to have a lot of people
potentially working from home they can
no longer do things they usually do go
to cafe go to a restaurant go at the gym
so how can i how can I make my routine
keep me sane okay so the probably you
and I Chris think you stuff left over
you and I probably have this weird thing
at the moment everyone's like oh my god
so late and you're like well yeah
suppose they leave the house slightly
less than normal but it's just normal
life for me everyone everyone just gets
to experience a little flavor of what
Jonathan Watson and Chris Williamson do
on a daily basis 9:00 a.m.
wank 10:00 a.m. isolation routine and
but on that on that and sort of thread I
think there's an it there's a you've got
to be careful because you don't wanna
have exactly the same routine like you
do have some potential to like go for a
walk on a Monday afternoon where maybe
you otherwise wouldn't turn or sit in a
slightly different room on a Tuesday and
you didn't mind it like you don't to be
too rigid but I think having a plan for
the day is probably the
important thing because otherwise you
end up just sort of like the hours just
bleed in the one the day's bleed in the
one you don't like what did I do sir
like what day is it
No so at the end of the day just
planning the next day with like the
people that your self isolating with or
like if it's just yourself just having a
having a plan of like right tomorrow I'm
gonna I'll do this in the morning and
I'm gonna have three hours off and then
I'm gonna you know create your own
structure that can evolve day to day but
I think having nothing and just winging
it and trying to get things done is it's
probably not I don't think anybody ever
really achieves anything major without
having some kind of intentional plan
first so you gotta have structure for
sure yeah I think the main thing for me
is to try and keep a semblance of what
life is usually like for you as close as
you can so you know get up on time pick
a time to get up get up and make your
breakfast go for a walk take the dog out
do the things that you usually do if you
can do them for instance if you're
working from home my advice would be to
get dressed for work that might not have
to be a full suit but go through the
rituals that are a part of your day
usually and the reason is that if you
decide to work in your like pants boxes
and a vest or something all day you're
not actually going to feel like you've
been to work it's going to further
create a alienation from what you
usually do and from what you're doing
now the same thing about going to the
gym if you're going to do home workouts
as loads of fantastic home workouts
available link to the one from propane
fitness will be in the show notes below
which you can do for free so you can
workout at home also some great ones
from warrior programming will also be in
the links below if you do to workout at
home
and you decide to just do it in your
pajamas barefoot in your bedroom like it
doesn't feel like you've been to the gym
so do your things you know like get get
a water bottle ready get your gym kit on
go for do the thing go for the run
because that feels like you've got some
semblance of normality still in your
life I think that really good point and
this is what Johnny mentioned that he
was struggling with a few months ago
when he
home gym which is the the closer your
gym is to your heart or if your gym is
easy in your house suddenly the idea of
just going for a sit down on the sofa is
two meters away it comes much more real
whereas if you have to we've all had an
experience where you know I can't be
asked to go to the gym but then you
think okay I'll just go so you get in
the car or you get on the bike you go
over to a new building by the time
you're there you complete a full workout
because you're like oh I'm in the
building for the training no it's gonna
happen the ritual is a big part of it
okay so we are planning our day we are
making sure that we have a stable sleep
and wake time were not just lolling
around in our pants and a vest or in our
pajamas doing a workout what we do next
Jonathan okay so the I well Pat perhaps
quite a lot of people I know wrestle
with this thing where they really want
to try and build a morning routine for
the first time they want to try like all
of the about this stuff that we talk
about a lot in life hacks and just on in
modern wisdom in general I suppose but
they wrestle with this thing of like
well I wake up at 7:00 and then I'm like
running down a hill trying to catch a
cheese you know there's that that
village is everyone seen a people trying
to catch that she's like trying to just
get to work and I get to work how about
then I sit down at my laptop and quietly
type away for eight hours and then do
the same at home like now you don't have
that you have this ability to create a
bit more space
in the morning so there's a real
opportunity to create this thing that
you're constantly kind of in graining
and reinforcing over the next however
long we're all in isolation for so
picking things that make you feel really
really good for the rest of the day that
make you feel more productive make you
feel more organized you're a lot more
likely to get more out of the time or
each day and in the cypher
self-isolation in general if the first
like hour to 90 minutes of your day is
just spent doing things that make you
feel fantastic
rather than like slamming loads of
coffee down scrolling through Instagram
watching like oh my god the news says
the world's gonna end today oh I better
check my emails like compare the two
thing I like use of some
FitPro morning routine the
anxiety-inducing morning really exactly
um I couldn't agree more so for me this
is the main takeaway it's the main
opportunity that most people have at the
moment which is you can do two things as
far as I see you can exist and survive
well there's a third one you could die
but no one's going to do that because
we're social isolation we're being safe
you can survive this particular period
this next whatever it's going to be four
weeks eight weeks 12 weeks perhaps or
you can flourish during it you can come
out of this experience better than when
you went in and the fact of the matter
is you have less distractions there is
never been a better time to go sober
there has never been a better time to
develop a meditation routine or a good
reading habit or to start journaling or
to learn an instrument even if you walk
to work from your house you've saved the
commute every day and for most people
I'm going to imagine the commute 30
minutes 45 minutes that's an hour and a
half a day 45 minutes each way it's an
hour and a half that's just been re get
'add back into your life so how are you
going to spend that time so I couldn't
agree more this is the opportunity you
have to get rid of bad habits and
develop new good habits and a morning
routine for me I think is its number one
on the list all of us have one for that
very reason because it is so important
so scope any thoughts on that habit
building yeah so so far really like good
points about the structure being blue
being so important that when people
don't have a structure it's very much
associated with depression and
depressive type behavior when there's no
reason to get up in the morning or no
reason to do anything at a particular
time it correlates very well with the
behaviors that produce and are the
effect of depression the thing that
Johnny said about using this time to
turn what would have been a weakness
into a strength means that especially
we're even in a very real sense with the
virus is that not only do you put
yourself
from normal into the low-risk category
but then it means that to be really
unwell from that then whatever the
outside stressor is it has to then
dethrone you from the position of
strength into normal and then into
weakness so you're really creating this
this buffered position that you know now
the problem with protecting yourself
from a virus is that the the things that
improve our health are not something
that we can just flip on like a switch
now that we're isolated for seven days
like yeah obviously it's helpful to be
like oh well I I smoked up until last
week and I've quit now but and to be
able to really turn your body into
something that is resilient to a shock
like this does take years and now is the
best time to do it I think you said that
this is the the best opportunity where
we've got more time and more focus to be
able to do this I think it also makes it
harder in now the volume on our mental
noise has turned up because there is
only those internal battles to deal with
and so we're now having to and without
having a structure in place to begin
with it's gonna be running downhill
chasing the cheese because the this just
is only the mental noise it's a paradox
of choice right it's it's the world that
me and Johnny live every single day I
had a message of friend who usually
worked in an office and is now working
from home and his message essentially
said mate I have no idea how the [ __ ]
you do this every day it's it's
destroying me is unproductive he's
constantly distracted he's always on his
phone he is finishing work it's at 9:00
p.m. at night 10:00 p.m. at night every
day I was like us
like and it's because everyone now is
feeling what it feels like to be a
self-employed person who works mostly
online it's great there because once you
got a handle on it it's it's so
liberating because then you really do
have command over your time but it it's
hilarious how like we've had this
repeatedly with clients who so with
business clients who we coach personal
trainers to help become online coaches
they have this dream that I are I can't
wait to be like fully in command with my
time and working online I wouldn't have
to go to the gym oh it would be well not
those people tell me what to do and all
this I'm in a weekend
they're just like oh my god like I
haven't trained I'm eating [ __ ] um like
my mental health is terrible and you're
like well this is it like you suddenly
you've grown up in such an
institutionalized acculturated way to
just follow instructions and follow
schedules and suddenly that's all been
thrown out the window and you're left
with
something that you haven't replaced it
with anything and so if you're somebody
that thrives on rules and structure and
you throw it away of course you're gonna
be miserable of course you're gonna
you're gonna feel chaotic
I think the the solution to that is as
Johnny said make a plan so looking at
the list here plan your day have a
stable sleep and wake cycle get dressed
for work get dressed for the gym build
habits create a morning routine what's
next
Jonathan just related to that so again
um there's just another what seems like
a really weird story but does anyone
remember reading about the guy who went
into a cave and deprived himself
completely of not of any artificial
light it's a new one read that no I know
Albert Marcus did it okay but he ended
up like falling into a little bit like a
biphasic sleeping pattern but I remember
thinking like man how awesome would it
be to be able to just have cuz that
that's that's a world where he's just
like removed right any sort of
artificial structure that exists and
he's like I'm just gonna sleep exactly
how my body wants and I'm gonna feel the
best as a result right so this is
exactly the same thing where probably
for the first time in most people's
lives they have the pressure that just
hit the microphone they have the
pressure that was always decided when
they do what they do is no longer there
so like you probably are all still
trying to keep a nine-to-five life if
that's what you've done but you can
completely design your day to be exactly
how you want and as Yusef says like
that's either an opportunity to let it
absolutely fist you and you end up like
at midnight still doing the same thing
you're doing at 9:00 a.m. yeah all you
can just create the and you'll realize
how much you can get done if you sit
down and absolutely focus for 90 minutes
or have a genuinely like free evening
where you don't have to think about
works you got so much done during the
day so it is such an opportunity but it
just I think you have to take it
seriously I think people who as you say
like if you're taking working from home
like you sort of sat on the sofa with -
is a [ __ ] - yeah I've got time off
I'll do what I want yeah like to treat
it like right this is my I'm gonna build
a routine here that's gonna last after
this so that even when I go back to work
I'm more productive I wake up at the
same time every day I'm getting more
done
slingshot yourself into it like this
time next year I'm an absolutely
[ __ ] rather than yeah I'm like
I've gained five kilos yeah couldn't
agree more
so let's start doing round tables of
just little things that we can put in
him will we'll add them in as we need so
my first hack is create a space if
you're working from home create a space
that you're going to work out of so
whether it be stack some books on top of
the kitchen counter and work at standing
desk in the kitchen whether it be the
spare bedroom whether it be some area I
would advise not doing it in your
bedroom I would if you can I would have
a separate area for sleep and work just
because it creates quite a nice physical
barrier that tells you work has finished
sleep has begun type thing but I think
that definitely that makes a big
difference for me I have my work area I
have my sleep area you know I think
that's a great place to start
Yussef what have you got yeah very much
agree like segregate out where you're
gonna work and where you gonna sleep so
that you you know and this is the same
as having a structure of time in your
day but it's just physical structure
like boundaries within the space in your
house the other thing that I would say
is this is a time where
the news and social media and people's
minds are going crazy with anxiety
because you not only now to be have the
existing systemic features of anxiety
which are like or things that have
promoted that over the last ten years
we've seen that Google trend of people
searching for the the term like goes up
like fivefold or something over the last
ten years
because of probably influence of social
media expectations body image all our
stuff must've still going on on
Instagram now compounded with we're all
gonna die and you don't have job
security and curve it is is increasing
in your area and this is the death rate
today and here's the number and now a
lack of distraction there's nothing
going on people aren't outside with real
other people and this vacuum just sucks
in speculation I've seen the most
vitriolic debates I've ever seen more
than the general election more than
brexit more than you know like the final
of love island like it is you know it's
really serious because people have got
fuck-all else to do and there's
something for them to be worried about
it's a real melting so it's a breeding
ground for all of the negativity and all
of the all of that style of thinking
plus yeah like to be a keyboard all you
can do is be a keyboard warrior like
even if you're gonna sit on Facebook and
and then you also stuck with your family
apparently divorce rates have gone up
massively in China you know what it's
doing in your own bed if you don't leave
me alone I'm gonna poo myself my fridge
and in my dishwasher and well I know for
a fact I don't know about the divorce
rates thing but I know for a fact that
cells of sex toys have gone up by around
about 30 to 40 percent it's so true
thing like the effect on the markets
that this is having
so unpredictable I heard it's like you'd
have thought you would never be able to
predict like a year ago that in March 20
20 home gym sales and sex toys will go
up massively yeah and this time while
while the stock market is crushing and I
sure S&P um a couple of things I've seen
recently which are amazing have you seen
that it must be a television medium guy
American guy from maybe the 80s and he's
walking around and the video says what
it's like being under home quarantine
with your four-year-old and it's just
this guy walking around and he goes how
tall is that tree over there when was
the last time that you washed your hands
have you seen how fast I can run
what's that it's like just loads of
random stupid questions and I just
thought that must be that is precisely
why it's like to be with a four-year-old
and the other thing is I saw a tweet
yesterday from someone who said um
absolutely unbelievable
seeing your partner in full work flow
I'm married to a let's circle back to
this guy who knew yeah actually if
you've never worked with your partner
like your partner lives an entire life
that you are not aware of and you're
just being introduced to it now mm-hmm
so maybe that's right all straight
supplement that's maybe it I think so
there's a lot there's a lot of stuff
would be cool to discuss today of like
so the job security is another kind of
source of this anxiety which has just
been whipped away from most people and
you know most people do work in an
offline environment we don't have the
infrastructure to to really handle
everybody working from home at once and
there are still certain professions that
just need to continue running but to to
circle back to the the anxiety life
thing one of the key things would just
be to tune out of a lot of that
negativity like I've seen apps being
developed now of like the number of
covert cases on your menu bar so you can
keep up what's the
keep up to date with the the constant
threat that's lurking outside of the
door nearly here it's gonna be like an
uber app you will develop coronavirus in
its what does that help anyone I I don't
know what any of the news helps with
because like everybody knows there is a
virus so I know one can argue with that
so there is a virus and you might get it
so the only thing you can do is wash
your hands and stay inside so I like
once you've ticked that box like do
something else
there's no neat I like constantly be
reminded like oh [ __ ] the news ah [ __ ]
oh yeah just wash your hands and saying
sayonara afford you're checking just
checking that silicates like it's just
future based out of your control outside
for those two things so go go watch like
free solar or something I like to be
something interesting
absolutely it's why I'm so glad that the
guidelines is just here are five points
like stay away from Grandma wash your
hands you know like don't don't buy all
the toilet roll like just simply enough
and there's no you know we don't need to
go deeper into that like you're at home
doing to be the dad's army before yeah
you know you know don't panic captain
Mannering yeah that's it that's all
anybody needs to do just a guy who
doesn't no matter what happens it
something happens and he just comes out
with serious it is is is instantly in
that with don't panic yeah because
everything better if you just don't
panic it is will be better if people
didn't well the the problem that we've
got is the lack of things for people to
do is forcing them to spend more time
online and the the amplitude that we're
playing with of how just worried people
are and I'm anxious people are is
drilling it into them seeking fixes for
their anxiety in the place where the
anxiety lives so they're going online to
they're jumping into an anxiety pool in
a desperate attempt to try and cure
their anxiety burns which which isn't
working so I mean straight off the bat
couple of hacks basic stuff that we've
been talking about for ages
sleepy D phone outside of your room
don't use your phone before you have
breakfast on a more
a hard stop and don't use your phone
after if you can sort of a p.m. 9:00
p.m. on a night at the absolute least
one hour before you go to bed that's
going to improve your sleep quality
because you're not going to be exposed
to blue light it's also going to improve
your life quality because it means that
you're not going to be looking at social
media immediately upon waking and the
last thing before you try and get to
sleep on a night to add to that if
you're working from home work in a room
and have your phone in a different room
if you need whatsapp for work if you
need messenger for work if you need
anything else all of those are available
as web-based apps or web-based programs
for your laptop or just download the the
partner program onto your computer there
you go like you've saved yourself from
all of the [ __ ] that people are swimming
in on the internet it's the basics of
trying to reduce your phone set a hard
stop on a morning and a hard stop on a
nighttime and then reduce the use during
the day by having a physical barrier
between you and your phone there you go
it's not as if we need any more external
sources of negativity or bad news when
most people are thinking how am I going
to have a job when this is over or when
is this gonna be over or am I gonna die
or is my family gonna die and all of
these these things don't don't help with
yeah as you said when you when all you
have is those questions and nothing else
to occupy your time with no - no no
social events just sat in the house
listening to what's between your ears
it's the guy who has been coaching me
for awhile called I've mentioned a few
times Paul Moore had really bad and
still has really bad anxiety when he's
flying and so I've heard him talk about
this this idea that anxiety is always a
future based thing so he were always
anxious about a future that may or may
not happen or like an event that may or
may not happen which most be like some
people will be experiencing like on
turbo if they're normally anxious this
is worse and some people may be
experiencing it for the first time I
feel quite a relaxed person but his way
I love this so simple and ridiculous
when you listen to it but his way of
dealing with anxiety on a plane is he
makes sure his iPod is fully charged and
he just plays football manager the
entire time and he's like he gets so
engrossed in football manager that he
forgets
that he liked because his attention is
somewhere else the fact that he's on a
plane kind of for large chunks of time
completely loses sight of a fact so back
to having a plan and having an idea of
what you're gonna do in your day if it's
like what I'm gonna work to five o'clock
then I'm just gonna watch like Boris's
announcement on TV and then I'm probably
look at the wall and sort of thinking
watching Boris is enough anyway softly
spoken I enjoy a bit of Boris I could I
find him quite comforting yeah nothing
that thing that pissed everyone off is
when he said like oh well you've not got
much to be doing so you could learn the
harmonica and everyone was like oh
cheers Boris I don't know if I can pay
my rent this month and I've lost my job
and I might died but yeah I'll go then a
harmonica cheers hmm I mean I I know
that people get upset by this but if
there's nothing you can do about the
fact that you got a lousy job like
either doing nothing and worrying about
that or playing the harmonica like
playing the harmonica is better couldn't
agree more but I mean I don't like to
come across insensitive like I really
like his it is it was very broad his is
that unlike I think that his opening
sentence was like everyone needs to
prepare to lose loved ones didn't he
hold it like operation last gasp or
something as well that last gasp to make
to get ventilators or something it's ohm
excuse me do you think that's
appropriate language to be using the
guy's a break
the guys doing a live webinar every day
at 5:15 for free for free there's no he
doesn't even ask for your email address
to get people to like not cancel isn't
it what to cancel what water gently like
believing in him and this in the
infrastructure and listening to the
advice like he's selling don't leave the
house please don't leave a house and
people are ignoring him anyway yeah hi
it's like when you know everyone always
has this opinion of like Lewis Hamilton
should have gone round that corner
faster or that football manager should
have been done it better go like
everyone whose net was not in the
position always has an opinion on how it
should be managed but like you try
leading the country through a pandemic
and then then give your opinion but this
is the thing it's the the Facebook
politicians have come out of the
woodwork and it's the same people that
posted about the general election it's
like this man just found this man and is
is the Treasury just fund like 350
billion pounds to support everyone what
about the self-employed make because
what a real feel bad I'm not very happy
it's like yes obviously with in every
situation there's going to be someone
that gets [ __ ] over but for what it's
worth I reckon he's doing a good job so
we can get bogged down in in borås all
day simply found outside of your room
talking on to fitness
how can people ensure that they don't
let their Fitness fall away scope what
can they follow follow our hypertrophy
focused bodyweight program available for
free because we want to help you guys
you'll be in the link in the podcast
description yep
what's is the URL if people can't click
on that because sometimes so speaking of
which that some of the stuff that I've
seen on Instagram of people posting like
bodyweight routines and it's like what
was it called
glute thruster things where you do it
you're on all fours and you're just
raising your legs in the air it's some
posters saying guys that's like saying
you'll get a big biceps by doing this
like you you you the principles of
progressive overload still apply learn
you still have to actually load your
muscles if you want to make any progress
that's what should be a Boris's
announcement I know the virus I'm guy
but deplete calorie balance and
progressive overload
because of a pandemic doesn't if and
it's something that really irks me every
time I see it cuz you like just because
you training without a gym doesn't mean
you suddenly have to unload everything
and just like just kind of wait dance
around your room like you may as well
just go and read a book like you wasted
wasting your time just as much as when
people
like drive to the gym to go and use the
treadmill for 40 minutes hike it's a
nice day outside like you're still
allowed to go out like just do that so
the the things that you would need for
really making progress with your
training are one a goal so just pick
whatever it is if it's a skill like
handstand balancing that kind of thing
if those of people are interested in
trying that they've never got around to
it because the other stuff in the gym
gets in the way this is the perfect time
to do it
pull-ups get good at pull-ups get good
press ups those kind of things and you
can you can scale the numbers with that
and you can make the movements more
difficult so what you need in your house
minimum is a pull-up bar I've got a lot
of clients buying parallettes now as
well so they are like presser bars but
slightly higher but allows you to do
things like l-sits planche variations
elevated push-ups handstands handstand
push-ups so with those two things you've
certainly covered your entire upper body
and I guarantee the next six months even
if that's how long we we end up being
quarantined for there's way more than
six months worth of games to be made
with a pull-up bar and some paralyzed
yeah resistant exponent yeah so
resistance band very good for things
like rear delts and stuff that you can't
normally hit with a bodyweight movement
naturally if you've sat down a lot in
the house having a resistance band to do
pull apart us is one of the key things
that's really the main thing that I use
a resistance band for just to try and
improve some of the length tension
relationships and you front and back so
that you can improve your posture and
just a lot of your shoulder to sit back
where it should I think people get like
unless you are a so if you're a
competitive a high-level competitive
power lifter or body builder and you're
like building up to a competition or
like you're going to be in the Olympics
this year for example I I get it
like that's legitimately very
frustrating probably puts a real hole in
your prep but like also those people are
at that level for a reason so like
mentally they'll be able to deal with
the situation better than like the
average gym goer if they're not in Japan
yeah exactly if you're not one of those
people like having
six months out to do different a
different kind of training modality is
really not a big deal so don't obsess
over the fact that you're not able to do
what you think that you should know know
cuz people just do what they like doing
because they're comfortable with it and
the fact that like the potential of
doing something else for a while
is is stressful and a fool because
they're not comfortable with it but like
go and do by going in preview 5k time
like I can attest to the fact that that
is still over the last three or four
years the hardest fitness thing fitness
test I've done that and like some of the
CrossFit stuff that's a majority body
weight like there's a thing there's a
CrossFit there was only open it was like
seven minutes of burpees as many babies
as you can like go to go do that I got a
bet you find that difficult every Tues
every Tuesday if you do if you do not
necessarily every week but but the point
the point is if you are training for fun
or you're like so I see a lot of power
lifters for example am I use for you
getting really upset about it and like
well I don't mean to discredit their
what they're doing because I get it's
important to them but if they're
building to like a local meet and that's
all that's the result of this like get a
bit of perspective for a second and
remember that it's not that bad and then
see it as well actually I'm gonna use
this to like work on my cardiovascular
output I'm gonna use this to work on my
mobility and flexibility I'm gonna work
on like getting as many handstand
push-ups as I can and working on my
overhead like there are so many things
as a like an athlete or like as someone
interested in fitness that you could do
isn't necessarily what you have been
doing over the last year's oh that's
absolutely huge and it's yet when you
reframe it like that but it's an
opportunity like I've been training in
the gym for the last few years and
despite the fact that I do have kind of
these niggling handstand goals and body
calisthenics goals and being able to
hold a planche and do flares and improve
my handstand ability but I've always
been like are but it's hard and boring
so I'm putting it off so I've been
procrastinating on a training goal by
doing a different form of training now
it's enforced like the gyms are shut so
fantastic this is the opportunity to be
like right well if all that came out of
these next few months was getting really
good at that stuff
you've then ticked off a nice big
feather off your belt or whatever the
analogy if the if your main concern as
well during a global pandemic is the
fact that you can't place fifth in a
local powerlifting me well that's it
isn't it but just write that on a
post-it note and put on Google just to
remind yourself yeah endemic stopped me
from placing fifth yeah well so so I
suppose two things have comfort one go
watch useless video on what happened
when I stopped training for six months
cuz he just like not basically the
shortcut is nothing right
and like my deadlift so I did cross fit
for seven months where I barely did any
basic strength remit any sort of barbell
base progressive like 5x5 all that sort
of stuff
my deadlift went from like three twelve
to about three hundred and sixty seven
months of cardio based circuit based
training that is supposedly like really
bad for raced over all strength goal so
like probably and then obviously it's
different individually but probably you
aren't going to lose much like even if
you spend six months doing like yoga
flexibility cardio like build up your
chin up and you press up right you
definitely get down before you lit it
probably will be because then you you
know you've improved you flexibility
you've taken a bit of time off those
niggling injuries that are always
getting the scalp yoked
yeah improved your work capacity you
then come back you've got a bit more
training flexibility and you can then
come back to here training whenever it
happens there's also an article on
propene fitness because I think
offseason for a powerlifter
it's very good most but it applies to
like anyone who's been going to the gym
regularly for a sustained period of time
when was the last time that you took a
total total break from resistance based
training where you aren't like
constantly trying to add weight to the
bar add weight to the machine or
whatever you're doing most people don't
do that if you look at a pro athlete
right look at like an NFL player or a
rugby player they have structured breaks
in the trainings just constantly
stressing the tendons and ligaments
another greatly quite long these breaks
yeah
I mean now's a perfect time to do some
rehab movements like at dr. Sam Spinelli
on Instagram used to be the strength
therapist but changed his handle and he
has he's that's yeah he changed it it's
more like reasons don't realize right
well you know you saw on the podcast I
podcast with him a couple of weeks ago
and that'll be coming out very soon
anyway he's putting out some free rehab
movements do some rehab get spend time
doing the things that he said that you
couldn't do previously you know I have a
bunch that I dropped it with on the
podcast with Morgan Housel of other
things other ways to be anti fragile
during lockdown and why don't we just
keep on doing a roundtable of that now
for a little bit and then we can jump
back in so decorate a room in your house
okay I think that's you know I don't
have time for that I haven't buy some
paint decorate room in your house yep
Johnny I've not got anything to
contribute because I have less time if
anything I think something I should
something I should clarify and I think
this is the elephant in the room that
maybe not for anyone that doesn't know
it I am working on acute medical
admissions in the hospital currently so
I'm not self isolating I'm just white
the officer showing you what you are
jumping headfirst into the Rohnert so
all of my self isolation tips are very
much theory like I'd love to self
isolate right now so keen for it because
it would minimize the risk and we've
we've built ruptures an hour a day to be
able to handle that pretty well and it
can definitely be done but but yeah so I
haven't got the I don't got the time to
be decorating a new room in my house
what would you do what would you do
would I do
I mean thing is like my my other job
propane is just self-isolation based as
well so the other full-time job that he
does around his full day I thank you
doctor dealing with a pandemic that one
but yeah
but but actually the the main the main
thing that's on the top of my mind right
now and should be on everyone's is to
look after my parents to look after my
mum make sure that that she's getting
groceries and that and obviously like
I'm probably carrying quite a lot of
potential viral load all the time so so
I need to if I'm going to do that you
know dropping stuff off outside the
house I dropped off some flowers outside
a house yesterday for Mother's Day like
these these kind of things like that we
we need to remember that even though
we've got our own struggles at home and
you know the internal struggles and the
schedule and stuff we're all doing this
because people over 60 are a seriously
high risk of dying and hospital
capacities are going to become very thin
on the ground so making sure that we can
do what we can to look after those
people aren't so glad that like Tesco
and Sainsbury's have introduced an
elderly hour or a conformable people's
an hour because it is it's disgusting
like how individualís and self-serving
we've we are as a society when like
people are just clearing out all the
Michelle's compared to like World War
two when people still just got there to
their own share and had much more of the
community in mind with this so haven't
they've done a NHS stuff hour as well
yeah they 7:00 a.m. on a Sunday morning
or something which I was still working
at 7:00 a.m.
[Music]
finishing a night shift so but but yeah
like it's a good initiative like we also
get 20% off Pizza Express now that it's
closed about your buzzing about
restaurants don't know worries guys just
just going headfirst into into the
hospital helping you guys out but that's
fine just buy up all the toilet roll
give us five percent off subway will be
will be happy or marinara and that will
make it all better
I am I saw today something that was kind
of nice
one of my friends Holly March on going
to his parents for Mother's Day and his
parents were in
the conservatory with all of the windows
closed and they had like a little do
either side of the conservatory
as he was outside and they were inside
and as I noted in the windows well I
mean the [ __ ] viral loads not gonna
go [ __ ] never know man but I think
like the yeah I cuz he said you see
loads of people that the thing I cannot
get my head around right and maybe this
is I'm just missing the point but when
when I look out the window and there's
loads people driving around what the
[ __ ] you doing what are you doing what
what are you doing like I just like the
the government has said we recommend
that you don't leave the house never
know but that doesn't apply to me
because I've got the Pope and then and
then those same people complain that
we're self isolating but like if you
don't self isolate when you could all
you're doing is postponing what we're
gonna have to do like yeah what's the
sermon there's a lot of there's a lot of
you it's like the kids what the again
the problem is the the key thing that we
keep going back to everybody's
experiencing the same situation and as
in a general election
unfortunately the vote of a stupid
person is worth the same as the vote of
someone who's well informed and whereas
now the good actions of a person that
decides to be virtuous and responsible
are no way in no way can mitigate the
actions of a complete idiot the decider
the new hashtag is it's video video
video nice okay so what else well so we
think we've spoken about physical
fitness we've spoken about routines a
little bit of stuff for work how can
people make themselves feel less lonely
and and isolated I actually don't quite
like the term social isolation social
distancing would be a better term the
social isolation does imply that you're
actually going to be isolated socially
which is not a very nice thing for
people to deal with but yeah how can we
avoid the
get zoom like seriously so I saw a
posted the day of a guy who went for
beers with his mates over a zoom meeting
my my mate last night my mate last night
had a virtual stag do that's probably
that is brilliant
I'm supposed to be in Istanbul and David
Coverdale writes for the son had a
virtual stag do 20 people what what
software that ease zoom so download zoom
why download zoom wise oom better than
FaceTime it's you I mean where do we
where we'll be here for the rest of this
episode just talking about that because
that was what the intro to the episode
before we started recording was about
wasn't it
it is better as long as you if you're
gonna use it for serious things gets
good zooms just like Skype right yeah so
it allows you to have virtual meetings a
lot of like pretty big businesses use
zoom for virtual meetings and it allows
you to basically see all your friends I
think I think I'm not sure there's a
limit there must be a limit but you
could have most unless you have lots and
lots of friends
you could have meetings and people have
been I've seen people having dinner
parties
like drinks all sorts of things through
like because there's no reason why yes
you use like you lose the in-person
aspect but you're still being social
technically so speaking to people so you
think that you're trying to have video
call or phone call as much as possible
with friends to reduce that feel range
isolation get it get it in the calendar
get regular stuff in the calendar all
comes back to film someone I know who's
pregnant just got a present from a
sister which was a Facebook portal now
despite the fact that I like I wouldn't
I would never want one in my home I'd
have just to have a little Mark
Zuckerberg just watching and listening
all the time anyway you do have a webcam
and a Yeti microphone that's a touchy
computer me that's true but I turn on
when I when I want people there's no
it's not your turn it on when you want
it's also not like a Facebook branded
device that you stick in your living
room designed to but but yeah but either
way I guess it's a sweet gift
despite my listening what is it what
does it do it's just like a video chat
box that you put on top of your TV it's
got a widescreen lens and it's just
quite smooth video chatting okay so you
know it's just it's probably something
that the sales which are gonna go up at
the moment because just to offset some
of these social distancing the what's
the brand of I think you've got one
Chris the VR has us oculus a two-person
oculus as well
I don't know everything like virtual
meetings it's like you turn you right
and there's like an emoji you effin an
emoji Chris yeah I mean definitely one
of the most anti fragile things to Cove
in nineteen so far has been group chats
everyone that is listening will know
just how upregulated group chat activity
has been you know I have to say as well
the quality hasn't gone down if anything
the quality's gone up but the quality of
some of the banter that's gone on in
group chats has been great so whilst
we're saying you do need to distance
yourself from social media I think that
you need to account for the fact that
your lack of social connection is going
to lead to you feeling lonely and
isolated so that is not I I wouldn't
class that social media I think that's
direct messaging as well there's not
like a hundred people and people who
don't know but the negative effects of
social media are looking at people who
you don't really know on the newsfeed
and it's by definition because you don't
know them you assign this like idyllic
life that they're living and you whereas
actually like all the kind of
influencers on Instagram like they would
have carefully crafted that shot and
there would have been really writhing in
a sense of like agonizing wanting
approval and trying to promote products
and and actually when you're interested
in the group chat with you mates like
yeah that's it's the closest proxy we
have to have a nice tag to we're having
a barbecue yeah so did a podcast with
Lydia Dan with who's written a book
called friendship and in that she talks
about just how central it is to people's
sense of well-being but she also said
that the fact that you can speak to
people online it is not as good it's not
the same as having in-person connection
wait it's a hell of a lot better than
having nothing
so I love the idea of scheduling in like
video calls or dinner parties and stuff
that virtual stag do I think like
phenomenal a virtual night out would be
you know like just a remote night out
imagine what we would do what would we
do
yeah it would just be this wouldn't it
you would get a broomstick out and you'd
start doing handstands scone
Johnny you'd complain about the fact
that your hips are tight I'll just
trigger the fizzy water and drink loads
of fizzy water yeah so Johnny can you
tell us about this before we before we
go on about what my take on fact I think
you mentioned it on the last my last
life hacks
Yussef yeah yeah I don't worry it's
already been it's already been dropped
and I scorned it and now some people
have gone out and bought a SodaStream I
get tagged in stories what I mean you
need to be careful about what you
certain these life hacks because
unfortunately some people listen to what
you say like go out and start
carbonating your own water like it so
that's the thing Chris you don't have to
go out anywhere normally is you get nice
a laugh with all this because it's on
your Amazon affiliate links so either by
your your SodaStream even against you or
even against your advice at least
someone did tell they tell me they
bought a dog because I suggested getting
a dog there's no affiliate link for that
though there's not imagine if there was
referral the dog okay so I reckon we've
got because we're using a brand new
piece of recording software that journey
needs have forced me to use I have no
idea how long we've got left so let's do
another 15 minutes or so if we can we've
talked about the fact that you need to
plan your day how do I just salute back
to that joining circle back how do I
plan my day do I do I need a piece of
paper do I need a spreadsheet what do I
do
so I just use iCal and then what I would
suggest is the night before pick one two
three or thick one main thing and then
three let slightly less important things
write down a bit of paper or schedule
them in and then get try the free
version of
brain FM which is brilliant something
I've been doing recently so that's a
that's a pre life hack life hack that'll
be appearing in a life hack see it
basically plays you like binaural beats
that sort of thing but you can set you
can set a period of time so don't worry
about like setting a time or anything
like that or you don't have to go into
Pomodoro's if that's not convenient for
your workflow you can do like 60 minutes
30 minutes a 90 minutes of deep work or
creative work it plays nice stuff work
for that long and then get up move
around do something else and try and
just do a few blocks of those in your
day so rather than like scheduling
things down to the minute think right
I'm gonna wake up and at nine o'clock
I'm gonna do my first 90 minute blocks
and I'm gonna have a break and do
something else
I personally that's how I always I fight
trying to work for it if it's Pomodoro's
or an intense period of work then change
you change the room you're in or I go
lean out the window or something like
that I think I think that having an
inside having a he ever reign inside do
not go and see your mother I think that
trying to have a lunch break trying to
have an end of work deadline as well is
important like remember the things that
we said remember keep that semblance of
normalcy have if you usually work until
11:00 then have a little 15-minute break
and have a coffee then work till half
one and go down to the canteen you can
do the same thing except from going to
the canteen and it's going to make you
feel like life is a lot less different
and alien and away from what you usually
do I think the average knowledge worker
so like someone who's like working in a
standard so office based job with a
laptop will probably be amazed how much
you can do when people aren't
interrupting you and that sort of things
so that's why I'm saying like ha right
it is immensely difficult like
elite-level difficult to just do one
thing for a period of time like if you
that is just productivity that's it it's
just complete one thing at a time
uninterrupted undistracted until it's
complete so like right for things down
in a bit of paper and if by the end of
the day you've done them you are like
you are being extremely productive
especially if they're important things
so
try that to see how much you can get
done make it into a bit of a game
especially if this is new for you you'll
probably see a bit of a hike in your
productivity I like it Seth
anything that you think that we haven't
touched on so far
lets you just wave in a for the people
that are listening we are all holding up
the exact same brass and glass hourglass
timer bit brass brass bit glass sitting
as a physical manifestation of doing one
thing until it's done and the fact that
it's analog means that you can't lose it
on a screen on a different article it's
and digital yeah what else have we
missed off so I the only thing we've
missed off is that despite that yes this
is as you said this is social distancing
but that's not equivalent to stay in the
house at all times like the outdoors is
fair game and National Trust have waived
their fees for one of their places you
know being outside is so helpful not
just for our mental health but also
always like clearing out the house a bit
just getting outdoors that so much
exercise you can do outdoors as well
really the only tangible difference to
people's lives at this point is going to
be in
reaction with people face-to-face and
being in the standard place of work
except for me unfortunately but so in
the trenches in yeah and it's it's nice
to see more people out jogging more
people doing like pull-ups in the park
like that kind of thing and I think just
taking advantage of the fact that we
actually have quite nice weather right
now and being outside on your own is no
longer weird can't shut nature can they
can try they were manage yeah well not
manage in all of nature did you see
there was all of those rumors floating
around about how the army we're gonna
come and stand outside a Tesco and make
sure that you weren't leaving your house
and all this sort of stuff
I saw unbelievable post from someone who
presumably must be in the Armed Forces
that said isn't it weird how me and my
battalion have heard nothing about this
mobilizing of Armed Forces to keep
people in their houses but Becky 17 from
Wigan is absolutely certain that it's
happening today about like I'm not gonna
find it but so it was it the thing on
Facebook if like Laura Lauren on
Facebook said Lauren on Twitter's like
posted I think like to the president or
something saying we Americans need to
know a date for when this coronavirus is
going to end this is not fair on our
something someone replied being like I
said Lauren what you're saying is you
want to speak to the manager of
coronavirus we have did I want to speak
to the manager haircut as well yeah she
did I remember seeing that okay so go
outside get some nature keep a semblance
of normality in your day create space to
work create a morning routine the
opportunity to build habits get dressed
for the gym sleep the phone outside of
your room
propene Fitness comm / something for
your workout plan it'll be in the link
in the show notes below ladies one more
thing
oh the biggest is the biggest thing yeah
especially surprise so a lot of
personal trainers and coaches and class
instructors and everyone like their
business is just being absolutely goosed
like especially when the gyms are
closing as well so there's kind of a mad
panic now of people trying to set up
online programs and without the
infrastructure to do that it's gonna be
a fail so that's something that Johnny
has been working on this week to to help
help those people in that position to
don't starve it's it's so it's really
interesting because like it's every
again it's one of those things where an
entire industry is put in the same
position and so loads of people are just
thinking all right I'm gonna do this
online coaching thing now so everyone's
posting on their Instagram my online
coaching now available as though
everybody's been thirsting for is for
that person online coaching because no
one like no one's thought of it before
like it is a perfect opportunity but if
you get it wrong you just you just look
stupid frankly so like use it as an
opportunity to I think everyone's
worrying like oh my god I need to get
PDFs and homework outs of people but see
it as a warning sign like something has
happened that impacted my business that
I absolutely wasn't ready for
potentially my revenues fall in the zero
but is the market telling you that there
is a problem so use it as an opportunity
to it in this time next year if anything
we're like this would ever happen again
like the gym you work I would have shut
whatever have an online income stream
because the people who are not worrying
this morning or today in general are
people doing that conquers this morning
are those who have like fifty percent of
their income from online because for
them moving their offline clients to
online it's easy because they already
have the systems and infrastructure in
place so all you need to do is go to
propane fitness calm for staff modern
wisdom love it all the answers are there
I love the custom URL as well um prepare
Fitness don't come such modern wisdom as
for online coaches not for the your old
workouts correct and also just I think
sorry just one more thing I think like
it doesn't have to be if you're a
personal trainer like if you unless
you're someone who is salaried and
working um
working it for a specific employer I
think having some kind of self offering
like online I think more and more people
are doing it now everyone is an expert
in something yeah well right that you've
done exactly that
right like six months server is is that
is the same thing it's you having an
online presence and online offering to
help people with your expertise and your
experience there's no reason why other
people can't do that so it's it's a
great time to explore that as an option
I got it
other people so one of the main problems
people are gonna have bottom of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs money money at the
moment what can people do or where would
you send people other than potentially
starting an online business one thing
that I can think of is supermarkets are
desperate for stuff at the moment so if
you are in the throes of needing money
supermarkets a great place to apply any
other ideas about either saving money or
own every delivery like that there is
gonna be so much more delivery but it's
already on the uptick isn't it uber as
well is is a bit like it's that's thus
maybe for the where people are traveling
the real ballsy ones well so the this
was mentioned on your last podcast with
the kovat guy who was saying that people
getting the train or the subway that's
obviously an inferior option to getting
a taxi taxis still not ideal but uber is
gonna be edit to be exposed to one
person rather than random bunch of them
unless the taxi driver definitely has it
definitely yeah in which case super
spreader that's a real problem super
spreader
okay so uber delivery supermarkets
takeaway system open right takeaways
yeah but not hoc I don't like going for
Domino's bet they're [ __ ] cleaning up
dominoes dominoes wiping the floor with
in the moment literally what about ways
to save money at a time like this
most people who can be spending far less
sat in the house unless they're just
pounding the Amazon may be stay away
from Amazon yeah he tumbled down that
rabbit hole when you've got no income
coming in is dangerous isn't it like
come in first don't go on the website
Amazon
don't go on amazon.com that don't go on
something that has a one click purchase
enabled the only website in the world
where you can accidentally buy something
and have it delivered the next day what
about for the next year every month yeah
yeah yeah subscribe and save on
subscription someone's done that with
sex toys and they're just receiving a
dildo a month for the next I don't know
last one don't really know how they work
okay so we've talked we've got about
that what else can people do I mean
certainly prepping your food at home it
doesn't matter how many takeaways are
still open they're not as cheap as
making the food yourself so bulk cooking
on the mornings definitely gonna be a
great way to do things if if this is not
in line with the money thing but if
money's alright macro meals are like
that they just sorted me out they just
sent me a box that's just sorted me out
they talked us through so macro meals is
just meal prep but they do as far as I
understand nationwide delivery you
pretty much design the recipes they're
like 500 calories a box they're not
they're not the cheapest thing but they
are delicious and I got like I was doing
it weekly but I switched I switched to
monthly like coincidentally a while ago
so I did I mean there was a choice and
they come monthly or they they drew they
deliver the boxes to me now monthly yeah
you need to get ready for that
everything yeah so they're alders in the
freezer yeah but their last five eight
weeks in the freezer I'm a big fan of
meal prep companies I use the Fitness
kitchens but it sounds very similar and
yeah just they nationwide loud yeah yeah
it's brilliant that those sorts of
things exist cuz it I think initially
when they were launched all of it was
like the local restaurants or like
options and it was always delivered by
someone by hand whether this is like
it's DPD it gets left on the doorstep I
got a text when like Phil's gonna drop
it off like it's brilliant it is
absolutely brilliant so something else
thanks Phil um so final thing a final
thing I want to finish on for Youssef
what can people do to ensure that
the immune system do you say did you say
you said like Yousef you raised a deaf
guy is just cycled past wearing like a
retro cap mustache holding a coffee in
one hand and checking his phone with the
other hand and just like come on very
Mario Kart
yeah exactly like new eg maybe it was
ISA coronavirus if ever there was a time
for Luigi from Mario Kart to appear like
a hipster Luigi yeah amazing so yeah how
can people
how can people ensure that their immune
systems are functioning well and have
you got as someone who is literally on
the front line in the trenches have you
got any sort of messages for people with
regards to health good question
so the what we shouldn't be doing is
looking and unfortunately because of the
fear-based information online now there
is so much so much of people exploiting
like trying to give out bio hacks and
that that's that hoax red pepper soup
and I said coronavirus is also known as
red pepper deficiency syndrome and the
next day people cleared out the red
peppers from the supermarkets to make
this soup it's just like people are so
ready to believe that the one hack
that's gonna improve their immune system
or whatever it is that unfortunately
there is no prophylactic or kind of
licensed treatment yet for what's
currently realistic is that no condoms
yeah what's the same thing so is it
preventative for a car or a condom you
can wear a condom if you want and just
around the house but you can't still get
coronavirus or wearing a condom
yeah he said that that's very nice I put
it over my head entirely I hear other
other problems pretty good clean clothes
anyway like it's not the condom that'll
kill you it's more the lack of breathing
like that is true okay but yeah so the
main thing is simply minimizing your
exposure to it and that's just following
the government guidelines and also
minimizing your transmission or
transmissibility of it to vulnerable
people personally I can't do that part I
am being exposed to the maximum
potential of it and unfortunately the
combination of sleep deprivation long
shifts working working beyond my
capacity and being exposed to a lot of
it does mean that I'm kind of more risk
personally but luckily not everyone has
to has to have that level of exposure
I'm still maintaining as much sleep as I
can training normally taking vitamin D
taking zinc but those things are things
that I would do anyway they're not
additional measures and I think
ultimately like if someone is already if
someone's drinking or if someone's
smoking like but obviously there's such
low-hanging fruit obvious things to stop
but I've seen people walk past holding
like boxes and boxes of beers like
stocking up and is like what so you're
gonna be in the house alone and the
thing that you've chosen to stock up on
is is beers like something that's really
not gonna help with no garros one
replicate the red peppers in case of
light as well as the something I was
asked recently was should I stop
exercise like is exercise a is it is
that reducing my immune function is so
like if I'm gonna pick a time to do
seven minutes of burpees is now the band
is now a bad time does exercise
Suika scope it's great answer exercise
exercise exercise reduce immune function
or does it does it boost it you have any
something I was in the recover from I
see well obviously if you over trained
then yeah you're gonna be run down but
that's that's the secondary effect
doesn't it that's being run down from
the exercise but with a whip v as Johnny
is demonstrating now you'll know whether
you're over trained now I think that the
answer to that is just don't be an idiot
don't take the piss got you
micros micronutrients probably a pretty
good idea to try and ensure that you've
got as much of a balanced diet in there
as possible to continue immune
functioning properly like if you are at
home usually in a canteen perhaps are
you used to eating a lot of food out and
you start only eating foods that have
one color in them if you look at your
plate and the food's the same color as
the plate and there's only one color on
the plate probably a bad idea yeah I
mean if you defeat few making yourself
deficient in in things at this point
it's probably not the best idea but that
the main message has to just be
minimizing exposure because it's much
better to not get it and therefore not
have to worry about it than to try and
strengthen your immune system but still
be going out and still be exposing
yourself to it prevention is better than
cure
yeah do you think I'm I'm not gonna take
your answer as gospel but you think it's
possible to not get it do you think
though there'll be people who don't
catch it as in like if if people remain
isolated will that be people who just
won't get it over over a long enough
time lines right obviously at some point
we'll have to stop isolating so is there
a chance that you'll just stop isolating
and they're not oh I see that was boring
though so this is just my personal
prediction I think there will be areas
of the world
Louisville should be untouched by it
like little tribal populations and
islands and stuff where they're just
absolutely sweet there will be other
places
where
there'll be an initial wave and then
silence and then the occasional mini
breakout and then it really it's how we
deal with that mini breakout that
depends whether we're all gonna have to
go back into self isolation or not again
right yeah so but yeah like based on the
current predictions they were saying
with the correct measures sixty percent
of people are gonna get it I don't know
if there's numbers of change now and I
think these are soon okay and that's so
speculative the way that things change
they may well differ in soon but that's
what I'm once you've once you've
finished having this argument with
yourself Yousef let us know how you get
on and then we'll just see my face like
that
half and half okay I think we've got
some good stuff to go out there like
obviously it is a very different and
challenging time for people the change
in so much of our lives not just work
socially family the way that we can
connect to other people concerns about
the economy concerns about our jobs
concerns about where we live you know
there's a lot of reasons for people on
the surface to be anxious but the main
message I think that's come from this
today which is what you keep going back
to you journey is that there are certain
things which you can control and there
are certain things which you can't
control and by focusing on what you can
do which is wash your hands stay in the
house develop a good routine get enough
sleep eat a balanced diet try and train
every day get some sunlight go outside
like it is the basics it's the absolute
basics that we're trying to preach and
we've been talking about this for two
years we were cool about coronavirus
before coronavirus even existed so you
know stick to the stuff that you know is
going to move the needle as far as this
is concerned and yeah I think any hacks
that people have got any of the things
that people have found working really
well for them send them in I'd love to
share them we probably are going to be
doing I mean life hacks 112 which
what's up next i reaiiy don't want to
have to record it like this so if we
have to do another isolation Haxton
soviet and we can get some crowd-sourced
crowd submitted suggestions for how
people are spending their time but the
the main message from a kind of personal
sovereignty and opportunity standpoint
is you have two choices you can either
exist through this so you can use it as
an opportunity to flourish and if you
flourish during this period of lockdown
you're going to have a head start on
only the rest of the competition but on
you had you have not been in lockdown so
that is you know the opportunity to
transcend the suffering of any situation
which is being given to you like oh [ __ ]
this is so bad it's this than the other
and then to turn it round stick your
middle finger up at it and use that to
become better you can help some other
people and you can bring them up I mean
for God sick stop posting information
that hasn't come from a reputable source
stay off social media sleeping people on
outside of your room or sober train in
the house use the propane fitness
training home workout protocol and
that's it I mean what else do you need
it's like a it's like a pit stop isn't
it when everyone's got to go into the
pits and it's like some people are going
to put mint tires on and like make their
engine butter and other people are just
gonna have a coffee hundred beers a
coffee and a kick-ass while you are
making your engine butter and a red
pepper and a coffee KitKat red pepper
that's the super stack anything that's
some condensed blueberries right look
thank you gentlemen for joining me today
bit of a weird one for us not to be sat
in the room first everyone that we've
done over Skype actually over zooms
sorry but yeah thank you as well to
everyone who's tuning in I know they
it's challenging time at the moment I am
going to try my best to not just keep
putting out coronavirus related content
I appreciate that
part of my role is to remind you that
there's a real world out there so it's
not just going to be us talking about
this virus for the rest of time but as
soon as I can get ahold of the boys I'll
get them back on and we'll do this again
so gentlemen thank you very much links
to every
we've spoken about we'll be in the show
notes below propane fitness calm /
modern wisdom if you are interested in
starting up an online business or the
online workout will be linked there as
well for now thank you boys
wonderful speech easy
[Music]
you